Travel Oh God look I'm the marionette he
did a little oh and I won didn't ha take
that you've been you've been perturbed I
have beaten the system
I am the superior champion suck on my
balls
freeze throw freeze does that even mean
oh oh oh what am I trying to do huh oh
god why oh stop jerking off for a walk I
know what I need to do now okay try to
take number DOS that's not helpful at
all well I'm vulnerable fast once more
into the breach
nope not assistant thing barely that
might do it yeah I'm gonna win pelvis oh
this game is not as fun as it was
advertised to be I feel like if you need
to shout out fun your game will is it's
not that fun and my commentary is good
it's definitely good Matt put up up
Marc's commentaries best commentary boo
boo boo fireworks
Pinu Thank You speedrun have fun how
speedy do I need to go
oh my everything else
most of my boy let's try ass game
that did not bode well for me there we
go I feel accomplished even though I got
certain death and got no rewards for it
yet run you is this like the Wii U I
don't know what I say about a jet run
anymore
tomatoe a while since I've done one like
a legitimate jet one Sun stop fondling
very now oh whoa my leg got backwards
but it's okay I'll be fine I'm the
greatest jet faller baller what was that
just Dodger ball or faller than I've
ever done Superman neon what am i doing
about Superman
Oh Oh fine let's try this again bye son
you're not so good at that but frankly
it doesn't matter to me because I feel
like a winner oh winner placement one
two three four what am i doing one two
three four about a helicopter war what
am i doing what am I trying to do let me
out the box okay if I managed to kill
myself
oh I'm not dead oh I would survive for a
long time if I had to eat my own ham
hocks come on come on played my but
blame me up played me up and goddamn it
my ham hocks it bro Oh gonads
dangerously close come on come on come
on squiggle a little closer there we go
Oh a little taste on the button but
that's not enough you got to finish me
off
come on get okay you're just teasing me
now well there goes my mode of transport
oh okay alright hey how's it goin let me
just reassemble myself slowly arm goes
into the arm socket and I can't move no
more well press reskin tap what come on
perfect come on oh just finish me off oh
come on oh this is agony and not for him
I don't care what he's going through the
agony for me I'm gonna get this ain't
gonna finish me
you think I'm off a little wimpy baby
man that's the opposite of what I am
[Music]
okay I gotta tuck my arms in before the
end they protected me my goddamn arms
wait why am i celebrating this I try so
hard to murder someone seems like the
opposite of what I should do Mall throw
versus the darkness who the darkness you
say well I'll just add on to my
collection of button
[Music]
good jump don't go down here don't go
down don't go down that's like telling
me that I need you down oh I expected
everything to blow up just got off to an
early stupid god dammit right I'm a butt
so if you don't do it right away you're
gonna get done did dunzo oh god you
stupid sack of crap if you can't get my
but my my busting buncher's Oh God
trying get to the finish and have fun oh
[ __ ] god damn it got this oh okay this
really is hard huh oh sorry my
incredible girth got in your way but you
and I are gonna have fun later all throw
epic I'll be the judge of how epic this
be click for secret what click I can
actually click it yeah thank you Tim
more tools for murder that I wanted not
oh why why mark about like Christmas oh
that wasn't Christmas at all
it says Christmas market lark quiz in
what day did mark hit two million side
oh I'm good
Margalo video called ready for Freddy
what number oh god damn it oh yeah
Oh kids what's going on I don't know
time here Fannie's you get over this
obstacle stop humping it with all your
might and get over the goddamn obstacle
oh oh okay I'm gonna do this with a more
reasonable character I suppose miss me
dick bag oh that's how well I exploded
literally try this once more unto the
breach miss me a douche knob Oh what
happened
try it again I guess if it's worth
trying
oh oh oh oh god mercy mercy oh that's
that's impossible
how's anyone supposed to be able to do
that well not me again come on don't die
[Music]
squooshed markiplier oh no they took Tim
why do I get in the back of Wade's truck
okay I don't know how I'm gonna do that
but I'm gonna trap
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye